this is a production of cornell
university
okay thank you for the introduction uh
yeah so today i'm pretty much gonna be
talking about the work i've been doing
soil chemistry related work
unfortunately i wasn't able to give a
fly fishing related presentation
if i wouldn't go over too well for the a
exam but
i'll be talking primarily about work
that
uh i've done a lot of it'll be
preliminary data but also some proposed
aspects of the overall project that i've
been working on past three or four years
in graduate school
so
i'm going to start off by giving a brief
overview of what i'm going to be talking
about
i'm going to provide a background on
soil organic carbon and dissolved
organic matter absorption and soils
these are going to be pretty quick
then i'm going to move on to the
research questions
questions that kind of motivate
the project
i'm going to follow that up with a more
detailed
explanation of the experiments and the
hypotheses as well as data
that go along with the project
which encompasses both field-based and
laboratory-based studies which look at
widely different scales field-based
studies are more focused on the profile
level and the lab-based experiments are
on the sub-nanometer
in some instances level
and i'm going to wrap up with some quick
acknowledgments and hopefully have time
to field some questions
so soil organic carbon
why do we care about it it is the
largest terrestrial organic carbon pool
on the planet
this
estimate here on this figure is seven
seventeen hundred and fifty gigatons
which is fairly accurate uh but well
shouldn't it accurate but it's a fairly
accepted value
uh and that's big it's bigger than the
atmosphere and biomass carbon pools
combined
and the reason it's so large is because
the carbon in these soil pools is
considered relatively stable uh it once
it's there it likes to remain there and
the carbon there can have really long
residence times that can exceed 1000 or
so years
uh
the reason it's so stable
primarily is because there are some
mechanisms that are at play in soils
keep the carbon stabilized and
two big mechanisms are binding to
minerals and occlusion of the material
so it's not accessible to be broken down
a lot of the material gets in the soils
particularly in the subsoils through dom
dissolved organic matter
this is a major input of soil carbon
throughout soil profiles
and this is the fraction of soil organic
matter that is
in soil solution and is hence very
mobile on soils
so when soil solution percolates from
the surface
dissolved organic matter goes along with
it and the material is sequentially
adsorbed and locked up in organomineral
associations as the soil solution
percolates
the actual absorption process is pretty
complex as dom itself is not all the
components will absorb equally and it's
influenced by dom properties such as
molecular size the dom and the amount
and the properties of dom that
have an effect on the actual absorption
to soils they're sensitive to a lot of
different factors and one that we
understand fairly well is that land use
has a pretty profound impact on dom
and a real big one that we know of
and is actually relatively common is the
practice of tillage it is a land use
practice that has
a pretty profound impact on dom
character
but much of what we know is restrict to
the plow layer and what we know
is that tillage
tends to make dissolved organic matter a
little more humified and that is rich in
aromatic and carboxylic type
functionalities
so the molecular
structure and character of dom
how it actually translates to dom
absorption
is
not entirely known for a fact but there
is a model that has been presented in
the literature about seven years ago by
marcus claber and associates
investigating the way organic matter
tends to absorb and assemble at mineral
surfaces
and it's based on some observations that
there's a really strong adsorption of
proteins and other high molecular weight
amphiphilic molecules
and amphiphiles just going back a quick
refresher in chemistry are molecules
that possess both polar and nonpolar
moieties or functionalities
and these tend to absorb very strongly
directly at the mineral particle surface
where they kind of rearrange and form a
base for further organic matter
adsorption
and
dissolved organic matter
also absorbs not only preferentially
through these components but it forms
patchy multi layers on mineral surfaces
which ultimately results in a
hydrophobic type
hydrophobic um surface once the dom is
actually absorbed and this is believed
to be the result of
i should say that was inferred to uh
be a additional layers of organic matter
absorbing
so all these observations were kind of
taken together again and used to develop
this contemporary model that is
typically pretty well accepted
but there are some flaws with this model
it's primarily based on bulk type
observations and we're not really sure
how it actually proposes
how it actually translates to the
molecular assembly uh the model infers
molecular assembly but it isn't really
based on any direct observation of those
films and this is
i forgot to change that that's not
offset to suggest anything
and a lot of the measurements that
we use
to
a lot of measurements that were
formed the basis of that model were um
based on single soils where they have
dissolved organic matter absorption to
single soils
and these kind of measurements dominate
not only the the model's basis but also
much of what we know about dissolved
organic matter absorption in general
and these soils aren't necessarily
coupled as a soil profile would be
so we don't really know a whole lot
about the actual sequential
fractionation and adsorption of
dissolved organic matter through a soil
profile
and additionally
we're not really too sure what happens
when you modify
the soil organic matter and dom in the
top surface and its properties how that
translates to adsorption
both in
surface soils and the subsoil
so this kind of brings me around
to more specifically some of the
research questions
first one
how does preferential retention
absorption of dom translate to soil
organic matter on soil particles
throughout the profile
so
when
dom percolates and it
preferentially and sequentially absorbs
what ultimately is going to be retained
on soils and what will ultimately not be
retained
and the second research question if we
have a process at the surface like
tillage that is altering the dom
character
that is making it changing its chemical
structure or chemical size
how does this translate beyond the
surface if there is preferential
absorption
how does it influence dom mobility into
subsoils where it might be retained into
a stable organomineral association or
something like that
um
next questions i have two more research
questions are a little more
molecular level oriented and they kind
of are a little more focused at the
model itself that was presented
how does the actual process of
preferential absorption
play out
we have dissolved organic matter that
preferentially absorbs the mineral
surfaces and we can see this by looking
at single samples but we don't know what
the actual process looks like the
absorption process
isn't a single point so if we're
analyzing a single sample
we're missing out on some pretty
important details
such as
are we actually
seeing
a strong absorption of infraphiles
directly at the interface followed by a
subsequent reorientation or not
is it possible there are other dom
components that aren't rich in protein
or amphiphilic type components that are
absorbing first
these are some things that
we don't presently know all that well
and the last research question
how do these adsorb dom films actually
assemble at the molecular level again
the model is based on larger scale
measurements and if you have a
measurement
in scope that exceeds the actual size of
the film you really end up missing out
on the actual structure you cannot
structurally structurally resolve
the angstrom and small nanometer scale
features of these films so for example
if you're looking at this
entire film and you're taking a
measurement that exceeds it
in in scale
you might be able to measure it and say
okay this film is composed of four
orange spheres four green and four red
on the other hand you could do the same
thing with this film and come to the
same conclusion and clearly the assembly
of these two films is not the same
and this is something that
we were pretty interested in looking at
so i'm gonna get in now and talk a
little bit about the actual experiments
we have set up i'm going to start off
with the field based experiments which
are more oriented towards research
questions one and two that look at soil
profiles
so the field sites i've been using are
located in central pennsylvania kind of
down near penn state
it's down at the russell e larsen
agricultural research center in rock
springs pennsylvania
it's smack dab in the middle of the
state and nice and
nestled in between the ridge and valley
province down there
and the plots we're using
are part of a
longer tillage experiment that was
initiated back in 1978
and there are three overall treatments
that were used there was a chisel
disking a moldboard disking and a
no-till treatments
we decided to use the moldboard disking
and the no-till plots
because the moldboard disking is
probably a little more rigorous and
might play out in a more interesting way
and
these plots that are till they're tilled
annually in the spring
and
all of these plots
are
planted using a soybean oat and corn
rotation
and these plots uh the soil that's
underneath them is
what is known as the hagerstown soil
series
which is
an alpha cell developed over a limestone
residual
and it results in
a silt loam topsoil and a silty clay
subsoil
pretty smooth in
horizontal and the mineralogy of these
soils
is dominated by
iron oxides and illite primarily
and it's not quite so easy to make out
here but the cores on the left represent
a tilde plot and the ones on the right
represent a no-till plot
so within these plots
that we have laid out
both the tilde and the no-till plots we
have
sets of five lysimeters
and they're each set
actually each lysimeter is placed at a
different depth
we have lysometers placed at 72 50 35 20
and 12 centimeters depth and this was
controlled primarily by
the actual um
if we were to go too much deeper we'd
start hitting bedrock in some places at
least
so we had to be limited there
so with these lysimeters
we're going to collect the soil solution
and we're going to analyze it in a few
different ways
we're going to determine the amount of
carbon and nitrogen in solution
we're going to look at the dissolved
organic matter this is the organic
matter that has not preferentially
associated the soils it remains in the
dissolved organic matter fraction
and we're going to look at the relative
molecular composition using a technique
known as ftir
it it's used to
speciate
molecular functional groups
such as
aromatic or amide type groups
and we're also going to use a technique
known as hp sec
high performance size exclusion
chromatography to look at the relative
molecular size of the dom that is not
associated as this too
is a factor in preferential absorption
of dissolved organic matter to soils
so we're also going to collect and
analyze the material that is actually on
the soils
and we're going to
collect them from the same depths
at the lysometers we're at
we're gonna
but the cores be fractioned about into
five different sections
we analyze them thus far
for organic carbon and nitrogen
we also have the relative molecular
composition of the organic matter and we
will be at some point determining the
fractional surface coverage
so it's believed that adsorbs to form
patches on mineral surfaces it'll be
interesting to see
how these
structures actually develop throughout
the profile
so for question one we were more focused
on just in general
how does this partitioning play out
throughout the soil profile
i think some general trends are going to
be observed
first and foremost i think the material
that
is on the soils which is organic matter
that has over the years preferentially
associated with the soils is going to be
heavily enriched
in amide type groups
aromatic type groups and carboxylic type
groups and this is going to be
throughout the profile
there are there's ample evidence both
from laboratory and field-based
experiments in the literature that
suggests these groups absorb very
strongly to soils so i believe these are
going to be prevalent throughout
near the surface i think it's possible
we might actually be able to detect some
aliphatic and carbohydrate type carbon
that's only going to be present near
near the surface where we have thicker
films and perhaps
multi-layer type associations that will
be observed
in the dissolved organic matter the
material that will not be selectively
associating with the soils i believe is
going to be primarily enriched in
carboxylic type groups
and
we might see a little bit of aliphatic
type contribution
representative of smaller acids
so for question two
and this was the question again that was
focused
on looking at the difference between
tillage and no-till basically
investigating the impact of tillage
on the preferential association process
throughout the profile
we're going to be doing a comparison a
relative comparison between the till and
the no-till soils
and again i think in general these soils
are going to follow the trends mentioned
on a previous page but between the two i
think there will be some differences
that will be observed for example i
think the no-till soil will have a
relatively higher
aliphatic and carbohydrate type content
as the material won't be
as humidified or as broken down
in this in the surface soil at the very
least
throughout the profile i
think especially once we get into the
subsoils
we're going to go back to seeing a real
rich presence of aromatic carboxylic and
amide type functionalities
as for the dissolved organic matter in
these soils
i think
the primary functional groups that are
going to be present again are going to
be carboxylic type groups
but the no-till soil i believe is going
to have
somewhat of an enrichment of aliphatic
type structures relative to the tilled
soil which again is going to be more
humidified more broken down
more enriched in
in in more recalcitrant type functional
groups
so i've mentioned what we
plan on doing or have done to some
extent and the hypotheses so i'm going
to kind of show you guys a little bit of
the preliminary data we have from these
experiments so far
the organic carbon content of the tilled
soil and this is just one of the tilled
soils that is a
from the satellite simmeters that was uh
in the middle of the moldboard till plot
there's no real surprises with the
organic carbon content
within the plow layer we have a pretty
uniform distribution and below that
point it drops off
on the right there's a we have a carbon
zane spectrum
which kind of provides some insight as
to the actual
character of the organic matter that is
associated with the soils
and it's kind of interesting in this
case because you look within the plow
layer where your organic carbon contents
are
pretty much the same you do see some
differences in the spectra like there's
this little broad shoulder here
but throughout the profile and generally
speaking
what you observe
is a relative decrease of amide and
carboxylic type carbon
with depth
relative to aromatic carbon which is
seen to increase with depth
and this is pretty interesting
and a similar type trend is observed
with the no-till soils
at least with respect to the
distribution of the functionalities
it doesn't seem to be quite as
pronounced as it is in the tilled plots
but
you do see with depth the relative
intensity of these amide and carboxylate
type peaks here
with respect to these aromatic type
groups does change with depth
and organic carbon content is again
probably not much of a surprise to
anybody here
it's a lot higher at the surface
and then also undergoes a kind of
gradual decrease
but you can tell there's no real
homogenization there of the topsoil
so
i quickly showed you guys some of what
we know about the material that's
actually on the soils the organic matter
that is associated with the soils
i also took a little bit of dom from the
lysimeters and characterized it with
ftir
and these spectra are pretty interesting
uh
one thing i kind of want to get out of
the way first is that this peak here
at first i'm like oh it's great you know
i didn't think i was going to find much
organic material in this
solution
i saw that peak and i was fantastic
but then i noticed it looked shockingly
similar to a nitrate standard i had
prepared as well
so
and that's nitrate is obviously not dom
so that's kind of presented a bit of an
issue and i went and and
actually checked the concentrations and
there's a fair amount of nitrate in
these soils
but the good news is i also took a uv
vis spectrum of these soils which is
kind of used as a broad
is dom there is not their kind of
analysis and it is there
it has these characteristic shoulders
and
little like foot slopes there that are
indicative of dom
so
in addition to those
pretty stark nitrate peaks
we can discern a couple other features
primarily the presence of
carboxylate functionalities both the
symmetric and asymmetric groups
as well as
some presence of co and cc stretches
which you'll find in
aliphatic or carbohydrate type
functionalities
and again these appear to be somewhat
slightly more pronounced and enriched in
the no-till soil
but
it's hard to really say at this point
this is just from one set of data
so the conclusions from the field
experiments thus far
som character is not evenly distributed
throughout the profile
and this is again material that was
preferentially
retained and we're starting to kind of
get an idea of what's going on below the
plow layer in tilled systems and i'm not
talking about just the concentration of
the carbon but
starting to get a molecular
viewpoint of what the actual organic
matter on the soils looks like
not necessarily the
assembly of the the structure at this
point but
in general what it looks like and that's
that's a step forward
and there's still a lot of work yet to
be done
we need to go out and determine the
organic matter coverage of these soils
spend a little more time with those zane
spectra that i showed
of the organic matter characterization
on the soil
maybe try to make a little more sense of
them
it's also pretty critical at this point
to actually continue collecting and
analyzing soil solution and do it
seasonally because this is a pretty
dynamic fraction and it's
going to be important to make sure
if we see any differences or anything
interesting it's not simply the result
of a seasonal transition
it would also be nice to finally get
around to characterizing the size of the
organic matter in the dom now that we
know it's actually there
okay so that was the the field
part of my research and the general
project
uh now i'm going to talk a little bit
about the laboratory experiments we've
been running
so
we're going to we've used and are going
to continue to use a series of
spectroscopic type experiments
that will allow us to actually directly
probe the interaction of dissolved
organic matter as well as desi
model organic matter with soil minerals
on a really small scale
two techniques in general are going to
be used here
one of which is known as
attenuated total reflectance fourier
transform infrared spectroscopy
uh
for the sake of brevity i'm going to
call atr ftir from here on out
as well as x-ray photoelectron
spectroscopy or xps
and this will allow us to get in there
and really resolve some fine scale
structures
and
you know something on the order of a
couple angstroms to a nanometer to is
very much in play here and this is
what's exciting about this
so i mentioned we're going to be using
some dom models and these are going to
be useful
because they allow for a better
mechanistic understanding of what's
actually happening it's not as complex
as dom
so it's a little easier to discern
what's happening when you use model type
compounds that you can fully
characterize and understand
so we elected to use bovine serum
albumin
and dna
these are both biopolymers
and they're found not necessarily
themselves in soil like for example
you're not going to find bsa in soil but
you will find globular proteins
in soil and the general structure of bsa
and all proteins is pretty similar you
have a
a backbone
composed of amino acid groups that are
polymerized and you will get some
changes in side chain structure
as well
but these orient themselves in secondary
and tertiary type arrangements to give
what you see there
and this is a good model because there
are globular proteins in soil solution
and bsa itself is so very well
characterized so it we already know a
lot about it
dna
dna is found in soil solution it's
exuded by uh soil organisms and
is therefore readily available to react
with soil uh soil minerals as a part of
the deon fraction
and it like bsa is a biopolymer
only in this case
the main
backbone type structure is a pentose
sugar
that's connected via phosphate groups
and in the middle uh there are
nucleobases that are kind of used to
kind of glue the helices together to
form dna
so we also use model minerals in these
experiments they unfortunately aren't
very
compatible with whole soils that's one
of the drawbacks
the model minerals we elected to use are
ferryhydrate and montmorillonite
both very different but also both very
reactive towards organic matter so
it should hopefully give us a pretty
good idea of what's going on
with two different distinct minerals
ferryhydrate is a short-range ordered
poorly crystalline iron hydroxide type
mineral
and
its surface is composed of
hydrophilic ph dependent surface sites
as far as the charge is concerned
and the crystal lights that we
synthesized are pretty small they have a
real nice
high reactive surface area and they're
small
they're about 10 nanometers in size this
is an afm image of them so it shows that
general topography of the film of
ferryhydrate
montmorillonite on the other hand is a
crystalline two to one aluminosilicate
which also has ph dependent charge on
the hydrophilic edge sites
and the the structure itself also has a
ph independent charge that is situated i
believe on the siloxane sheet or perhaps
in
octahedral sheet in montmorillonite
so they're two very distinct minerals
we're going to use
so the one technique i mentioned
previously was atr ftir
and this is a suitable technique for
what we're looking to do
because it's highly surface sensitive
and it uses infrared radiation which is
very informative when you're talking
about
molecular level mechanistics it probes
molecular vibrations
so when you combine its surface
sensitivity with the information it
provides is a pretty useful technique
and it pretty much works by just
reflecting an infrared beam
off of a
diamond element which we have upstairs
in the lab
and when it's reflected it creates a
sampling wave that penetrates the sample
on the order of about a half to one
micron so
what that allows you to do is just look
at adsorbed molecules and not get as
much of a contribution from the solution
phase
so these experiments
again focused at the last two questions
that look at dom absorption process
as well as film assembly
are going to be run in situ so we're
going to deposit a mineral film on this
reflective element that i just mentioned
and as the material adsorbs with time
as it's drawn in like for example we
expose the film to a dom solution at
time zero
and as the adsorption progresses
material is drawn onto the film and it
absorbs and changes structures
until it reaches
what we're going to basically call an
apparent equilibrium
and at this point we can kind of
characterize the film
and then compare
material that's absorbed at all time
points to the whole dom and actually
look at the fractional
and preferential association of dom
so the other technique we're going to
take a look at is going to be
xps
and this is
surface sensitive like
in the same sense that atr ftir is it's
not going to get the whole bulk sample
but it's complementary
atr ftir will likely characterize the
entire dom film
this is only going to get the surface
maybe five to ten nanometers or so
and what this is going to tell us about
that surface five to ten nanometers
is
what's going on on the atomic level so
this is a an elementary specific
technique so it probes elemental
transitions
and these are they're going to be
sensitive to adsorbate structure so if
something adsorbs to let's say this
model mineral film
we should be able to detect the
structures
as the reaction progresses
and in addition to giving adsorbate
structure it can also be used to look at
the actual thickness of the xps films
oh excuse me the dom films as well as
the fractional surface coverage
so these experiments are going to look
like this we're going to expose a model
mineral film be it fairy hydrate or
montmorillonite
to a dom solution
we're going to take samples at a fixed
set of time points we have to work out
yet and analyze them with xps
and what this is going to do is let us
look at the surface most layer only
at each time point
and this will be very handy
especially when coupled with atr it'll
let us know not only the the bulk type
structures but also what the top of the
film looks like which would be useful in
resolving
assembly
so here's my hypotheses about what we're
going to see here
for question three how do i think the
actual preferential adsorption
throughout the whole process is going to
occur
i think that early on in the absorption
process with the models we're going to
see
approximate amounts of dna and bsa being
adsorbed to the minerals
i think once absorption is finally
complete though
bsa will ultimately be
preferred
i'll go and do this a little bit more in
the next slide
with the dissolved organic matter the
real
more complex solution
i think we can
kind of at least i've pretty much
assumed that initially we're going to
have a
real rich presence of aromatic and
carboxylic
type dom
and once the absorption process is
actually complete
this is still going to be the dominant
feature
but it will also be complemented by some
aliphatic or carbohydrate type dlm
so what do i think the assembly is
actually going to look like
i think that bsa
both on fairy hydrate and
montmorillonite
is going to form pretty uniform
multi-layers as it's been pretty well
documented in literature that bsa will
do
this um dna i think is going to form
patchy monolayer associations primarily
through binding of the backbone
phosphates with edge sites on
montmorillonite or directly on ferry
hydrate
and when both are present i think we're
going to have patchy type associations
of varying thickness
pretty much
where bsa absorbs first i think you're
going to continue to see a buildup of
bsa as the absorption progresses but
where dna absorbs first i think that's
going to be it i think
the remaining negative charge on the dna
will cancel out further adsorption
and for dom i think there is going to be
a uniform multi-layered
distribution on both soil minerals
with a base formed up of aromatic and
carboxylic rich dom
that
alpha and carbohydrate type
organic matter will then adsorb onto as
as
once the film was complete i should say
so now i'm going to quickly get into
some preliminary results here from the
laboratory based experiments
this is bsa again the globular protein
when we expose this to a fairy hydride
film we saw some pretty interesting
things
uh so bsa by itself in solution is this
black curve here
and you can see it's got amide one two
and three bands
in the spectrum
and these are basically in reference to
bsa structures pre-elementary structures
on the bsa
but upon adsorption
which is this red curve you see here
after five hours it had pretty much
reached equilibrium by then
you see
some side chain vibrations pop up
but we're definitely most interested in
the amid one band as this represents
some pretty key structural vibrations
and this is typically used to look at
protein conformational change
so when we take a closer look at the
amid one band
we see some pretty interesting features
the band itself is composed of
three different components one of which
is assigned to beta sheets which is a
type of secondary structure
one is
composed of uh or
contributed to by beta sheets and turns
and alpha helices and random structure
so
these are all secondary type structures
and we can see
that in solution we have this
distribution
and once
the bsa absorbs we end up with a
different distribution we saw
some pretty substantial changes
throughout the absorption process and
this suggests that there is some
conformational change of the protein
and the conclusion from the infrared
data that you see up here was pretty
much reinforced by the xps data
the black curve you see on the bottom
is bsa the standard we were using and
the red curve
uh represents the
bsa that is absorbed onto fd oxide
and the spectrum shows the c1s amide
transition
well i thought the spectrum the spectrum
in general shows the c1s transition of
bsa
but you can see there's a change in
increase in this peak here
which is uh the amide contribution to
the spectrum
and this again suggests that something's
going on throughout this absorption
dna on the other hand uh
there are no amide bands so what we look
at
structurally
uh
it's typically considered
what we typically look at when you look
at dna structure
especially
talking about absorption
is you look at the the backbone
phosphates to see if they play a role in
this case it looks like they do
again the aqueous phase spectrum of dna
and this is ftir so it's looking at
vibrations is in black
and once it is absorbed onto iron oxide
for about five hours or so it's
you see the spectrum that popped out in
red
and there is a big shift
in both anti-symmetric and symmetric
phosphate vibrations
upon adsorption
and this insinuates that there is
perhaps a direct binding of the dna
backbone to the fairy hydride surface
possibly through a hydroxyl type
replacement mechanism
and this is also reinforced by xps again
if you look at our dna standard that's
down here in black
and the
phosphorus transition
of
the absorbed dna
you can see there's a
shift in energy it's an increased shift
it's hard to really make a whole lot of
sense out of this at this point but that
is indicative of some kind of a chemical
change occurring to phosphorus because
this is an elementally specific spectrum
for p
so the mixed systems we combined the two
like i mentioned we were going to do
previously
and
the solution again is here in black you
can see features from both biomolecules
in the solution spectrum
upon adsorption
some things clearly happen
it's hard to say exactly what because
there are some overlapping bands
and this is where the xps data really
became really helpful
because it's difficult to discern a lot
of structural information from that but
the xps data kind of shed some light on
on the structures
and this is the c1s so this is the the
carbon spectrum of the one to one
material
and you can see down here in blue
is adsorbed dna
and up here in red is adsorbed bsa so
those are the individual components and
when you combine them
and you look at the adsorbed film from
the one to one experiment you can see
that amide one bump is appearing again
so it kind of looks like bsa is
reorienting even in mixed systems
but it also looks like phosphorus might
be as well
this top peak here is the phosphorus of
dna absorbed by itself
the bottom peak in black here
is the dna standard
and in the middle this green peak is the
the phosphorus spectrum from the
combined system
and you can see there is a slight shift
as in dna absorbed by itself
of the phosphate the phosphorus peak
so
both of these spectra kind of show that
there
there is still some structural
alteration
and likely
direct coordination
or association of both at the interface
another thing these xps analyses yielded
which i thought was pretty cool
uh
was the the actual ratio of the
biomolecules that were absorbed using
the p
signal we can see how much it was
diluted
in in the one to one where there are
both biomolecules
and we did that and quickly looked at it
and saw that there was a relative
proportion of sixty percent bsa and
forty dna absorb kind of suggesting that
both were
neither one was severely out competing
the other which is kind of surprising
so the whole dom experiments
uh this is dom i extracted from a
no-till surface soil using a water
extract i passed it over a ferry hydrite
film for the course of 12 hours
and kind of
what i'd expected in the hypotheses we
saw a pretty nice enrichment of
carboxylate type groups compared to
the whole dom
i should probably go back the whole dom
is here in red and this is the dom that
has not been fractionated by absorption
and as material absorbs it becomes
increasingly rich and carboxylate type
groups relative to carbohydrate groups
which is kind of the opposite of what
you might
see in the whole dom which is richer
totally speaking
in aliphatic and carbohydrate type
vibrations
so some conclusions from the lab
experiments
the preliminary data they reveal some
new perspectives on organomineral
associations and soil organic matter as
a whole
a new approach to dom adsorption has
been developed
kind of looking at the process in situ
and then monitoring it with xps
separately is
pretty new and i think it's going to
yield some good results in the end
and the mixed systems to show only a
small preference for amphiphiles which
is in pretty direct contrast to what you
might find in the literature
and in particular uh
the foundation of this claver model that
i mentioned earlier
and there's also still a lot of work
that needs to be done
i need to run some more absorption
experiments
perhaps try using dom from lysimeters
which is a little more gentle perhaps
more relevant rather than shaking it out
in a lab and beating a dom out of the
soil and there are a few other things
that need to get done too
sorry to run short i wanted to have some
time for some questions though quickly i
want to wrap up
i'd like to acknowledge my lab group
anita martinez aubry fine mariella
garcia
the folks
all you guys here in the soil
section of soil and crop sciences here
at cornell
as well as the folks down at the
department of ecosystem science and
management at penn state for a couple
years of assistantship support
now my funding comes from the nsf
cross-scale biogeochemistry program here
at cornell so i definitely like to
acknowledge those guys
as well as
scientists john schue mark beason and
mary severson for
preliminary data acquisition
and last but not least i would love to
thank you guys the audience for sitting
here and listening to me
and i welcome any questions and or
suggestions at this point
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu